mais le truc c'est que ça vient pas nous
parce que si saab venait de mon ordi
doit attendre et attendre aimons sont
mauvais alléluia ouais moi j'entendais
très bien le terrain
ouais non mais je sais que ça va bien
c'est un patois c'est les gens ils sont
très nerveux dans le tchat
les gars il ya petits problèmes qui sont
quand même assez grave dans le monde
pour lesquels il ya des soucis avec les
serveurs internet faut raison garder
être un peu plus calmes coiffa je sais
pas vous êtes en bonne santé vous êtes
chez vous tout se passe bien ça va il ya
un problème de serveur faut pas
s'exciter à fond comme ça quoi
non mais je sais garder gens qui sont là
mais je repars là on peut avertir et
tout ça mais il ya des gens chez qui ça
a marché
elle est bizarre c'est ses problèmes
avec les serveurs les machins ça peut
arriver en ce moment c'est comme ça
c'est la vie
1 il a ajouté 4 talus way dont un
spoiler encore mes pions prend je
préfère lui apprend qu'elle prend 2,8 et
moi j'ai les cheveux la même
j'ai travaillé la même position avec le
pion blanc
comment ça marche 1 à 4 est le pionner
en 1 6 mais il ya je vois pas de
différence fondamentale
je préfère les noirs dont ses besoins
moi aussi moi ici
donc a donc là on aime bien les noix bon
ça doit être jouable pour les blancs
pour pas non plus déconner mais plutôt
plus agréable ajoute aura huit cavaliers
qui bien sûr f4 très clairement une
meilleure position
après il me semble qu'il ya une nulle
dans ses positions inca veille un
sacrifice et un prix qui fait nul
bon bah on retourne chez maxim pour
l'appel quand même un petit peu il a le
tour un chant sont trop surprise ouais
donc on avait dit quoi caillassant et
pour échanger le tour du canton prend ou
alors que je te prends un chanteur prend
un tour inscrits sur six ans reprend
rapport ça me paraît même mieux sage tu
comprends que les blancs sont un peu
mieux dans répulsion dépasser ou quoi le
roi un poil plus faible mais pour moi
y'a rien la ligue et si je suis j'ai
piette g pyatt 5 août
j'ai fait cet échange est en jeu 2 et
revenir un peu dans 9 4
un attentat pas d'âme c'est cette
guérilla simple 2 qui va traîner je sois
pas convoqué vois pas comment les blancs
non maximino niveau pour laténium et
ouais je trouve ça un peu désolé mais
c'est désagréable pour les gars de notre
niveau mais pour maxime ça va aller pour
maxime ça va aller attends je vais quand
même faire un petit retour d'expérience
par rapport aux trucs twitch quand même
[Musique]
le youtube a coupé c'est vraiment
compliqué quoi où la digue
elle c'est génial dit je l'avais youtube
a coupé sana parlant c'est quand on a
coupé messieurs seulement ça ça marche
mais ça du coup ça temps ça a changé le
titre mais oui du coup ça fait ça par an
que ça fait planter le truc tu vas t'en
faut que je fasse un petit truc mathieu
ces rondes 6 e julien oui il ya un truc
de jean faut qu'on aille voir ça c'est
drôle
wang hao il a pas l'air concentré je
suis assez d'accord c'est un branleur
alors née peau à regarder il y a fait un
chemin cash 4 c'est ça fait il se prend
à chaque partie à chaque 15 4 du coup le
fait lui-même mais n'est pas qu'ils
jouent tempo presse baisse enfin tempo
il a pris dix minutes pour faire baisser
un v6 il laisse le pion à leur âge 3 il
s'en fout totalement il a dû analyser
dit sur comment ça marche il faut
calculer un b c'est tombé huit libye
menace d'un boycott mais au quai d'alger
cat aura toujours d'un prendrait 5
théoriquement non je bouffe eux deux et
j'ai cinq ans l'air ok donc voici donc
tourbe est un donc je le coupe plus
logique tourbains ou 124 5 2 mais la fin
quand tu prends je sens que ça ok donc
tu peux pas jouer si simplement comme se
méfier un petit peu trois des familles à
4 4 mais est-ce que la finale gagne
prise prise resort 4 prises source
attends je vais de quel côté le vent en
achète où je vais lancer dans cinq ans
en tout cas je vais travailler h3 je
vais revenir on chez 4 ouais mais ça me
fait passer et rien leur tour ces sept
vasistas et marans un f3 ou des fois tu
peux faire le tour du roy et fuite
[Musique]
c'est dangereux at elle trop c'est quand
je voulais faire brasser système
printemps des six échecs
non là les blancs sont en danger ok donc
il faut revenir un si vous entendez peur
c'est normal tu as une petite seconde de
juste ce petit retard pour voir si on
peut arranger le truc ou assis aussi à d
pour avoir moins de problèmes
[Musique]
il est je t'aime point est bon mais
quand il est vrai quand il enrage qui
joue le personnage est un pauvre il
échange qu'il a trouvé plus simple pour
défendre les cases blanches et le roi h
avec l'idée quand il menacera damas
trois je te ferai kg un jeu mais je
contrôle tout mes cases blanches et d'un
pacage 3 way
alors attends maxi 1000 à brion achat il
va jouer pour la suite en espérant que
la finale ils la tiennent facilement ce
qui est probable c'est la position soit
chic et de disney ponant dîner pose
qu'on était en train de faire c'est une
analyse il a joué tout le match en tempo
on va discuter ainsi que des cuves à me
faire un truc que je kg un garde et h3
on target protéger mon rang est tombé 1
bessette et je dois te côté mais c'est
sûr mathieu qui l'a utre a analysé le
truc pour prendre des essais ces
décisions là aussi vite mais les blancs
les noirs je t'aime pas logique
mais bon ce qui est fou c'est que pour
moi c'est pas la lune critique ce qui me
tue mouches tombé 1 kg 1 md et en fait
on va bouffer comme des suppôts faire
croire c'est fini je pense sans perdre b
sanader samana très dangereux la raison
c'est sûr monciné pro gagne ça lol non
mais bien il faut que les autres
derrière commence à virer des parties
puisqu'il aura déjà un point d'avancé à
mi-parcours
j ai envie à ses points de permis pas
pour demain oui mais encore enfin après
demain ah oui c'est repos de mon or ok
c'est repos devant donc ouais bon du
coup sa bouche mv elle aurait forcément
forcément ça rentre dans la vente qu'on
disait où ça va tout est changé mais
reste que les plombs peuvent être un peu
mieux on va essayer de réfléchir
stratégiquement prise prise je pense g4
c'était un peu le coup le plus ah ouais
j'ai 400 passagers font b5
stratégiquement installe du sens
pas moins je vais faire jessains donc
[Musique]
t'as fait quoi tu as fait la marche
quatre talents paraissait logique
moi j'ai deux je tenais en g8 pour
éviter de me prendre un truc sur l'échec
de 5 qui venait 1,5
tata et c3 pas content tu couvres les
cases domaxis un manant talent je suis
un 5 1 4 ouais mais jeffrey k way ou 7
[Musique]
tu prends des quatre vêtements dans la
machine c'est pourquoi la dame prend 2,5
ya pas de geste on peut continuer encore
de saint jacques
h3 g7 fait que nul non bref klf 6-3 et
puis qu'est 17,3 g8
il n'y a pas de maths non ça a l'air de
tenir mais oui c'est peut-être qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent un peu avant son nez
pauvres veut gagner franchement nous
pensons n'est pas aussi gagnent quand
même forme on peut jeter un oeil au
classement ils la 3éme et les autres
maxime il aurait un point avant ce mois
un an et demi probablement un point d
avance sur maxime est un point et demi
d'avancé sur les autres c'est vrai que à
mi tournoi c'est quand même une belle
avance quoi mais après des ponts on sait
qu'il peut en perdre deux ou trois la
philo est arrivé deux fois les magnans
évidente est très fort mais pourtant je
me sens qu'il a progressé dans la tête
donc il peut être dangereux
alors je vais faire un petit tournoi
pour que pour si les gens veulent le
jouet qu'on en faisait tous les jours ça
me demandait deux petites minutes
ouais on a commencé ça on a commencé
salah à la ronde 2 donc lorsque tu étais
pas là aujourd'hui 14h on va le mettre
on va le mettre sur deux heures
c'est pour les gens qui sont dans le
chat qui veulent jouer ça permet de
passer un peu le temps tu as pour les
gens qui veulent s'ils veulent aussi
jouer aux échecs
est ce que c'est possible de mettre un
prénom ou pas écouté hier avec l'un
crémant il y avait trois plus de là on a
fait cinq minutes tu aurais tu préfères
froid plus de 2,5
donc tu bookwalter une fois et malgré le
taux de personnes
wei s'inscrivent ils viennent vers world
championship mais qui s'inscrit on en
est encore loin mais petit à petit il ya
eu déjà mieux qu'on en fait c'est sans
doute mieux ouais mais c'est théorique
en fait c'est ça qui est drôle mais j'ai
vraiment joué la même - c est du monde
n'en voulait que huit personnes
oui la fois une femme on a parlé pendant
une heure ils et 320 toi la fin ou là
c'était la guerre il faut avoir le coup
est parti minimum pour pouvoir
participer à la reine à 5 avoir suivi
cinq parties me home / chasse comme sk
nba la fille de tours à huit ans sur à
main ça j'avais laissé les classements
et tu vois ça ils me le disent pas
fighter ils te disent tous à un truc et
puis après ils te disent pas bon après
on n'avait pas on parlait pas vraiment
les positions tout offrant un bureau
apprendre aux élèves de chine ouais
ding et dong dong donc profitent
directement non quoi ça peut transposer
dans les it again tu as plein de
positions qui peuvent revenir ou au sol
et sur la les quatre cavaliers fougue et
5 et la partie de geri on peut la voir
c'est exactement la même position juste
les collections acquis doublant un
camion mois 1-5 qui ont insisté pour que
je me suis père marché à dieu tout le
monde ravi de vous avoir connu a pris
car wayne ne faut pas l'enterrer
parce que great chaude parce façon moyen
terme même si pour l'instant il est
solide et m ouais ouais c'est pas ici
paris se passe il se passe pas énorme
pour le moment aujourd'hui surtout la
partie de dépôt je trouve qui est
intéressante genre dans la partie de
maxime aujourd'hui c'est bah c'est
peut-être sa partie la moins
passionnante ans à maxime depuis le
début du tournoi aujourd'hui
ouais parce que seraient couverts du
trio de son adversaire heidi peut rien
il y peut rien il y peut rien il est
venu avec une idée lot sauf que dams est
ça refroidit son idée mais je serais
curieux d'analyser le g4 là qui nous
faisait un peu peur la passe de rêve de
mais peut-être qu'on avait tort en l1 je
regarderai après la partie
donc ouais le pian achi fait peur mais
en fait moi le plomber me fait plus peur
si je m inquiète 20 juin et je vais te
dire comment qui va mater sur quatre
grands champions des cinq de gênes le
pion détroit contre leucate la case r3
et contrôler qui peut jamais attaqué son
père dont fo de gazon en attaque face à
metz cocasse blanche par définition
après peut-être qu'il peut y avoir une
sorte de blocus entre guillemets car
comment est-ce que tu peux aussi un truc
d'hommes dans dix-sept aussi soudé pour
600 kg 1
fu dix huit ça ça déjà on est peut-être
moins bien parce qu'on va voir une
finale à quelqu un doublé d et
probablement qu'on va se rendre vite
avec un paiement à la fin
cad un des deux plans d mais j'ai envie
de te dire c'est peut-être un moindre
mal je montre pour illustrer un second
devrait améliorer avec les blancs
légèrement on va perdre province ou
alors pas d'ailleurs probablement un
pion mais on a quand même des chances de
tonia retour à 3 sur tours d2 y avait
cinq balles c'est pas beau hein c'est
pas moche même qu'elle prend des singles
athènes le tour allait quand même pas
trivial j'ai même pensé à tour derrière
normalement oui mais ce n est pas sûr
elle est passée inaperçue à 100% autour
de 6
elle est chiante un mets d'ailleurs
c'était mieux de faire tomber cinq pour
des simples pour empêcher leurs autres
ce que tu peux pas m'empêcher d'aller un
dessin tu gagnes pas vraiment un temps
mais bon ça j'imagine qu'ils avaient
mieux que ça pour les mains et c'est
pour vous dire que les normes peuvent
essayer s'en sortir avec un sac et ouais
c'est non mais c'est hyper dangereux
meding finalement il aura bien joué deux
parties contre caruana et hier balalas
encore un point d'ouverture ce thème
c'est terrible un bon s'ajoute un pot
car on a encore une grande avance pour
ne pas mes supérieurs
il a quand même une sacrée mémoire aussi
mais pour ce qu'indique un beau et que
20 ans fait les 3 ouais tu aimes bien il
ya maxime une bonne mémoire
voilà c'est tout les jours 1 et poker
est bien préparée quand même il a été
mal préparée où il ses moyens rappelé
conques à roanne à nancy contre gretsch
la verrine aux taux bientôt bekkat était
mon mieux
ouais d'accord qu'est congrès tous qu'il
a été moins bien mais au delà mais icade
caruana à paris hier où il sait pas
rappelé il est au dessus en prépa oui ok
car à nagui option prépa aînés poèmes vl
derrière finalement mais pas loin
une grève au niveau pré paille la bonne
foi donc c'est il fait exactement ce
qu'on dit autour de 9 8 x 2 l'immmédiat
from à 2d bekaert faut bien j'y avais
pas pensé
peut-être sa naissance de rebigue adsav
aspect p4 farina donc bekkat yémen le
fou soro 2 mais dans ces cas là autant
aller 1 à 2 et l1 ces quatre mois il
serait mû en le 2 a donc fait x 2 go 4
ou 6 4 avec les b 5 qui traînent armes
en est à plus de 124 oula ça c'est dans
mon camp je m'y attendais pas mais c'est
un leurre ce vendredi c'est dans ton
camp ça et je me tournais haffoudhi cet
opus vous inscrire pour jouer s'il vous
plaît peut-être répond à
oui mais il faut s'inscrire au club
c'est les gens qui veulent mettre le
lien et après le lien du club et après
il ya le lien du tournoi que je vais que
je vais remettre ici donc je sors mon
épreuve gérer qu'il gagne le tournoi si
tout aussi vite contre carlson qui
déteste les parties longues car celles
qui détestent les parties longues pris
le doigt dans tout les cas d'andré bon
alors on s'arrête peut-être un peu sur
sur quoi chercher plus m'arrêter
mathieu laças je voulais revenir revient
au tout début au premier ouais 4,5
j'avais mon truc plusieurs trucs disent
on est rock et si des 3 2 6 7 3 1 à 6 un
câble soit 7 h trois cavaliers de cette
quête des 2 kg si disons qu'elle est f1
sait si fou mais tout cas les trois
studios des cinq pions prend non pas du
kung fu qui les prend kerry 4 apprend
qu'elle est pensée ça ouais et prend ici
le bon coup pour ce théoricien cette
peugeot le bon coup ci c'est flou 6
donc ça veut dire que ça ressemble un
petit peu quand même non ouais mais j'en
ai une autre
ce soit dans le même genre le 4 5
les 6 et 7 points et six fours b5
comment ça marche comment ils
commenceraient transposer une même idée
de rich iott nom des trois ans rock rock
des six cavaliers eux deux ouais
cavalier seul
ouais ces trois faux disons que j'ai
trois des six faut être quatre kg 6 rbds
et tu peux arriver avec les mêmes idées
des quêtes et des fois ça peut être
foulard inverse était faut rien attendre
plus en cette ligne je sais que j'ai la
même son mécène la position de la partie
exact ça m'a l'air d'être plutôt une
bonne version pour les pour les noirs
parce que le pion à 5 il n'est pas
dégueu le fonds s est aussi le flou
c'est de ce qui serait pas mieux en b3
j'ai envie de te dire si on bat le mans
sous le kg 600 pêche l'attaquent
après je sais qu'il y avait des lignes
quand j'avais analysé ses positions il y
avait vite des cavaliers cinq cavaliers
f5 et des fois il peut y avoir des nuls
je me rappelle un ianine brésil joue les
sept joué lès tours 8
il ya eu des idées des fois base de
cavaliers à chaque fois çi ce camp prend
dames 2 2 des fois y'a des trucs comme
ça qui peuvent marcher mais là je là je
pense je fais fougue et 8 et je suis
bien où je sais qu'il ya des lignes
c'est pas là mais qui peuvent marcher au
fouet cinq gammes de deux tu menaces
fois çi mai donc du coup et la position
de me semble juste bien points noirs
mais la pollution donc l'idée c'est que
ce recalage 5 on a je pense que tu auras
8 c'est le coût qui doit jouer et après
l'idée c'est que maintenant on a fool v8
tout le temps c'est hyper chiant à bord
je prends les noirs tous les jours c'est
fou beaucoup comment ça se fait que tu
peux pas c'est tellement dur de
rattraper le cap de la préparation pour
alex enhco parce que ça fait quand même
peur d'être mal avec les blancs après
quinze coups c'est impressionnant non
c'est beaucoup mais tant qu'il réfléchit
ça va bien faire une demi-heure à jann
marc et 20021 une minute mais ouais il
depuis cet hiver seront ou hangars où il
a joué daems et dante 3 et de jeux
dessins qui est voilées jouent la finale
ou quoi mais ton roi je sais ce qu'il
peut d'être sous les 2 sous b 5 baies 5
il ya cinq dames c'est 7,4 à vrai dire
il faudrait peut-être faire fuser 3
encore madame ne sont jamais faits à mon
avis c'est peut-être des cinq jours
vient de prendre le sens nantes est
caressée si tu reviens bêtement wa fouet
trucks tu viens ou 3 il y aura des
échecs quand j'ai cinq sites sûrs par
angers 1 tu vas être loin et tu vas
laisser des trous charge
c'est un peu bizarre comme de pins ouest
ça doit aller mais on croit g7 paraît
logique
ok juste regarde des cinq 5 ans de 6
c'était mon idée mais je pense pas que
ça marche mais je vais faire des six
avec les dames france et trois clés
france ces trois cas il prend ses 4 17
c'était le regarder le foot c'est 6
qu'est-ce qu'il ya pas de cinquième
manche cas d'échec elle fossé côté
entreprises le détroit du malheur des
sous je leur ai tu souhaites tu le
plaquent safe et me donner mieux suzuka
les projets cette part est logique sur
le site et pas vraiment limitée ici
trois jours d'un match 4 y avait eu sept
ans qu'est ce tu peux jeu comme moscou
foulée 5 ou des 5 1 c'est le 2 kung fu
bessin cavalia 5 et il n'y a pas d'âme
ce 7-6 alors apprendre comment tu fais
fi 3g 3g indien c'est quand même triste
g5 pour l'heure le mot même dame c'est
fou non après c'est pas juste pour
répéter maxime il n'a pas joué comme ça
pour éviter la nuit les jouets le gain
il faut pas le cas ici il joue pas la
ligue 1
mais il va la tenir mais d'ailleurs tu
es 3 gbit plus humain pour pas se mettre
sous 24 mois mais c'est pour protéger la
table en fête
[Musique]
du coup à vie dans ce même public en jeu
c'est parce que des saints que je peux
le sait la tension parce que dame prend
ainsi 3 prend ça mais c'était mon idée
mais bon ça ça coûtait veilleuse mais ce
que ça c'est un problème enfin non de 6
2 6 2 6
mais les 6,3 fuite fin après peut-être
sous-estimé relance est à 0 mardi dans 0
8 mois ça me ferait pas super peur mais
aurait dû avoir des trucs l'effet peut
être quatre cinq mois 3 il veut aussi x
4 nombre vient wen a encaissé un peu
pénible on croit j'ai cette rue malin
parce que tu peux garder l'attention
c'est l'idée de base devrait way dams
3par a joué 40 la part de west et bien
joué que ça un peu sa force à calculer
des fous bessengue mon x 6 non mais faut
b5 et des cinq ponts sont en l'air est
ce qu'il ya eu des coups joués dans les
autres partis là on va regarder à la non
ça joue pas depuis une demi-heure à la
il a fait fou derrag reach ou qu'on l'a
déjà à la ninkasi pkd food de l'attaqué
mettez y aurait paquet bassam alain
sémalens bécade co2 qui est bessin qui
elle tombait car c'est ce que je dirai
d'accord donc il a trouvé la ligne ou
c'est mieux d'être un des enjeux 2 que
c'est qu'à la fin j'ai envie de te dire
combien il lui reste deux temps palmarès
six mois et 16,8 pour jouer dix sept
coups coiffage eric et tu l'as trouvé
très bien bravo à toi tu as toujours un
truc un petit peu plus fin mai mais en
fait tu as perdu une heure 40 pour le
trouver quoi enfin n'ont pas de place à
l'énergie chaque fois beckett fou de
retrouver alors est-ce que vous prend
ainsi c'est une menace
pas sûr parce que l'on ne peut être
enfermé faut regarder
si je prends cavale et prend un risque
et ses cinq dames c'est cette jeunesse
tourbe et 7 aces contre la dame on
dirait non dame c6 fou 17 tu perds la
dame quand même rey veut dire qu'il faut
2 je peux jouer un coup d'attentes
ça veut dire que faut que tu peux jouer
un coup d'attendre
j'enrage si ce n'est pas hitler away que
peyo ça me va satané à 4 h 7 sa tête
enlève des matchs du couloir
moi je pensais aussi à j-6 d'hommes g7
mais ça à mon fou on n'aime pas trop
jouer g6 avec un foie est simple qu'un
jour il y aura des jca t on n'aura pas
de casse d'euros pris sur sa diagonale
donc ouais donc achi s'est mieux battu
par des jets 4 car il ya quatre ans
ouais ouais non c'est pas glop seul nom
âge c'est ça il a fait quoi un parti l'a
fait b 4 voit donc beckham va être jouée
fous eux deux il va faire acheter
sûrement après quelques chocs est connu
pour ses secondes balles autant mais pas
de tabou est beau mâle autant même lui
dit qu'il est très content quand il que
ça tient contre maxime par exemple pour
prendre un exemple
il s'est quand même retrouvé
complètement perdre en deux coups au
début de son keynote donc attention à
l'ordi à peine une année coding nous ne
met pas sa position il à faire ce qu'on
pensait ah non il n'a pas fait en lui
n'a pas fait avec la dame en baisse est
compensée qui bloquerait parce que là
est ce que ps est ce à un coût pour un
set
ouais mais est-ce que je suis pas
content de te faire bloquer pions ici
djorkaeff 4 ouazar au fond mais cette
[Musique]
prise de notes
non là je perds peut-être une pièce non
ce secteur
mais non j'ai pas de cage de 3,5 en
effet pas une caisse qui est mieux non
ça je vais perdre et prendre ton échec
était papa
[Musique]
saint ouen bouge tes prend un point
juste par curiosité ça ça va le quoi ça
donne gagnant belge et tour des simples
se retournant que s'entendait 5 c'est
peut-être nul une victoire et cinq sets
gagnants attendant le 6 super g qui on
obtient la même source si je fais mais
si tu veux m'aimer cinq dames de hockey
ne me dois tu peux peut-être que tu te
fais quoi bon mais là on est parti loin
mais du coup donc bessette n'a pas l'air
si clairement donc alors juste ex
transformatif or zidane b5 les logiques
face tu calcules prise prise donc hsbc
main stadium alain gagnon tourbe et
cette force l attente en tout cas les f4
way at on précisé
après les chipeaux cette fatigue même ça
c'est pas nul qui avait princes 3 1 je
montre un jus ce que je me suis pris le
chinois mais juste tu fais avec art et
légère 1
pas mal pour une fille lisse car elle
prend des semaines d'abord je suis là
d'abord tu prends parce que moi je me
demandais en fait la question que je me
posais mathieu sait ce que ça c'est une
question du prix est ce que ça c'est
gagnant ça parce que si ça c'est gagnant
tous gagnants c'est ça la question
fondamentale ce que je gagne des sahwa
ces gagnants c'est sûr j'ai gâché cette
réunion j'ai jaugé 4 way home 3g 4,94
millions de bep trous ça devrait gagner
donc du coup ça veut dire qu'en fait tu
fais d'abdessamad et peut-être jusqu'au
peu de manginhos enfin mathieu béda le
chandail rouge au cut off
en fait ça de toute façon tu obtiendras
jamais mieux qu'un échange massif
il ya un clouage quand même su prend du
fou en fait ça fait aucun matériau on
est d'accord comme evans je regarde
comprend des cinq qui gagne le pion de
ce fonds prend en stop your way et quand
tu fais tout reprend non je te prends
des 80 ans du temps où je les ai vus
donc du coup j'ai ici vous le fou tu
reviens oui tu vas revenir et tapageur
tu gagnes tout ce qu est la même en fait
c'est la même
ça servira même au final tu en as donc
d'enlever cinq ici joue d'alger quatre
dames g4 c'est seul coût de 9,5
[Musique]
donc du coup fallait pas d'amour il
fallait un lien sa 5000ème que tu prends
des quatre sur tempo du coup même si ce
nom d'homme jacques catz ne paraît pas
clairsemés des cinq faux précise
possible
ouais ok sur ton progrès social tout
ramata la fin un non lieu d'un point en
huit manches pas messi a demandé à m je
venais d'apprendre et 4 assez bien c'est
pas si simple seul coup car il a joué
donc ça de beyssac ci fait d'abaisser
ses coûts qui répondait cats logique et
la dnef s'ils sont atteints ou d'objets
cut zabrze 4 mai 2006 et les mêmes idées
ouais c'est pas si simple simple
par contre au québec 7 de ce tour cette
dame de saint cloud b6 ça marche ou pas
la crise et surtout reprendre entre
enfants et au caire et à froid je prends
bessette tu prends mais c'est ça c'est
pas que ça ça doit même 5 le clou j'ai
quand même chiant mais si j'arrive à je
vis tu partiras demi-tour ailleurs ça
peut se sauver sa vie à l'appel d'un
maxi d'alger 4 ce qu'on avait dit en
premier des cinq d'un médecin qaïda
adam j attends il peut peut-être
bessette en oublier il y aura 7 5
cette fois je peux plus prendre mais si
du cloud ça m'a l'air d'aller st ouais
tomber qualité en d4
les prises de catherine bessette oui ça
marche tombé à prendre cette des casinos
maintenant montana pour dender tanger un
tour d un tomber at il fait comment on
vient je fais dam des huit noms ces
jolies teintes restée vide triste car
c'est mon héritage de 3,8
bon ben c'est moins violente est
notament des sacres dame v5 pas si clair
ça veut dire que ding grosse de fond si
ça marche
alors attention fait bessette mais ce
tour à cette barre des 5
je peux prendre 2 c'est très durement
que celle de l'autre slash prend 17
ouais non c'est chaud chez moi il ya un
petit bruit de fond de temps en temps
c'est un bébé dans la pièce d'à côté des
fois il ya une petite musique qu'on
retienne l'endormir ne se sent-il c'est
une petite jolie berceuse hassan ouvert
soit une verse désolé mais ça s'arrêtait
bon donc ça c'est chaud grisha il a joué
le feu 2 dont on a parlé on va voir
comment on avait 10 h his way
ah ok on me fait signe de s'arrêter un
peu ashes comment font les blancs faut
qu'ils ramènent un cavalier fouet fin
fond du aurait tours 8
intrus dans l'avion bien tf1 c'est un
bon coup
si c'est dur évalue ses poses des noirs
c'était du mal à bouger ses salariés en
fait il faut trouver un planqué b5 donc
il ya des cats
est ce que c'est si c'est une idée parce
que la dame défend le pion déçu ce nom
qu'après prise cavaliers prend il ya
cinq qui traînent ou des fois je veux
juste simplifier la position à attendre
m'attaque de pièces foot des c4 est un
peu des présents dont provient j'ai pas
un autre cavalier manqué processus d'amd
5 j'ai plein d'autres
oui si le cavalier 5,6 genre qu'ait lieu
cinq pieds et prend faut six ça ça peut
peut-être faire nul parce que je veux
dire voie d'un bush puis on prend xb à 4
ou des présentations sur a6
oui mais c'est pour ça que je voulais
attaquer b2 mais je veux d'adem le
défends mes joueurs car il ya quelques
semaines autour des 8 face à un peu
artificielle quoi ça passe peut-être
mais ok donc ceci s'est pas trop une
idée enfin peut-être que oui mais un peu
bizarre mais du coup quand tu sais ça
avec les non ascii si tu fais pas fou 17
avec l'idée fouet fin celle ci cependant
très fréquent est ce que c'est vraiment
une idée on n'en sait rien moi je te
fais réjouissent avec les blancs quand
même un peu moins ouais mais l'énorme
talent du mal à bouger
wade pour maxime on est plutôt qu'ils ne
gagnent pas aujourd'hui fo prend 1,6 en
fait remonte au tout début ça marchait
pas peut-être qu'ici ça marche mais dans
l'absolu faut prendre 6 marche rarement
est ce que tu te fais enfermer la lame
prise qualifiée 5 est tombée cet
apparemment pas non tu peux peut-être
juin six barres déjà ta part en cure de
maternité apatam s'est vu juste et
menace d'ouragan à éviter
la dame sort plus non ça c'est une bonne
question ça fait partie des trucs mais
là car oneapp et là je faut deux mois et
demi la jette ça ça il avait depuis
longtemps en fait faux de banaliser le
truc après faute puisqu'il est joué mais
là car rona j'allais dire il pleut il
pleut il pleut tank est tranquille dit
la thur oui bah c'est le premier pour y
réfléchir
il sait juste que leur dis que ça va
mais à mon avis n'est pas allé plus loin
dans la nuit c'est sûr il sait déjà très
loin il est au 24e coup oui c'est
peut-être un peu entraîné des pistes
d'entraînement ou moins ok alexiane co
donc tu auras 8 jouer ce que disent les
uns c'était pour moi le bon coup les
normales jeunes cavaliers f4 des fautes
tu peux même repartir avec ton foncez
vite maintenant qu'à passer la torah mon
fond c'est 8 il est déjà développé
puisque tel point je crois c'est la
différence d'avec ou le pur h trois
options h 2 il y aurait eu des fois il y
aurait des fous g4 mais oui en énorme
préfère légèrement inondés que le cliché
trois bougies à fouquet 8 il est mal il
est un peu sous pression c'est moi je
pense qu'il va la perdre et maxime il a
fait rager 8
d'accord c'est bien que des 5 c'est de
l'eau pour le donc voici céline
conditions des cinq prises sur les lieux
cinq et six mois les fuites foule de 300
quoi juste pour des sujets précités
sûreté les premières 17 et dans sa
région de matam et 3,8 ou b 3e 5 il a dû
le g3 8 ce genre de lui qu'il faut
calculer mais c'est un peu disons
si tout va bien les connaître c'est
finale mathieu j'aime pas trop mais
attends je vais te pensé un temps qui
peut pas jouer cavalier ou 5
ce sera un artificier l'a23 dans ce 3e
je veux pareil que le roi qu'est devenu
quelque chose avec les blancs là je suis
moins bien
la témoin bien claire bazy donc des cinq
l'écran et on a l'impression du moins on
n'est pas expert qu'il est un peu
imprécis au passage ses empreintes des
simples photos d'avant on prend des
jeunes je pense qu'on prend du fou parce
que cavaler à 5 qui pour simplifier
akébé 5 qui doit gagner du méthane va
pas pouvoir tenir les pions comme ça
qu'elle sait faire avancer cette ça va
faire mal à 6/4 et laissé 7 et j'ai
quand même gagné 6 mai rock et c'est ça
ma choquer surtout sévi le truc c'est
que le carré l'île hors jeu aussi un
autre problème les rôles trois séries
mauvaise finale et après on va pousser
la majorité des lois
ça fait mal il a fait dès samedi donc
d'un procès 3 français 3 sekai à dammaj
quatre échecs aussi trop un jeu 3 2
matches 2 mais je crois d'un mage
d'euros 3 tut tut tut tut on voit loin
de debug april est capable de calculer
nulle force et un ouais je suis à
quelques messages jusqu'au bout d'un
match 6/4 et des affiches 4 il estime qu
à jougne ses cheveux non qu'est ce que
tu as we came là et après les fraîcheurs
cède 1.66 mais j'aime pas trop d'un
match que j'aime pas trop des simples
d'un point ses trois cahiers pendant
organisons cette finale
ne me prend 7 3 4 en finale de 5,6 vers
le centre c'est ça la finale
concrètement c'est la position qu'on a
eu à savoir est-ce que sk l'injustice
3,8 ce que ça s'arrête pas est ce que
c'est une force à sa manière et je sais
pas s'il est perdant mais il est moins
bien pour vous même objectivement c'est
eux cinq pattes asie donc agent va me
prendre risques et cinq coupes et venant
dé 6,3 fuite food et 3g 5g trois ans
pourquoi j'ai sonne c'est comme on veut
faire un nul ils menacent f4 autant
simplifier la pause balles échangées le
manipule un maximum de piano j'ai trois
miroirs 8 pb 5 entre asus nous seconde
armée sacem et f caprice prise yoshiki
les 3 6 ans qui assume un ouais on bouge
aussi 400 une option ouais mais je veux
le faire dans tous les cas au coup
d'après je rêve que les profs ou kfc cas
disons mois de 7,5 sexy nul pour moi
elle doit être nul salle à 1,6 à
lessines mais il ya quatre mois doit
être nu le matin tu vas te faire f 6 tu
vas être changé tu as changé encore un
peu et on n' ya pas assez de matériel
pour gagner ton carillon c'est ça qui
protège aussi ça doit faire nul lille
comme dit magnus
maxime adore défendre des positions
inférieur c'est son actif parce qu'ils
pensent aujourd'hui mais c'est pas
complètement faux c'est finalement ryan
ans c'est vrai mais après le problème
c'est que ouais non là il ay l'agrément
qu'une chance de 1 par endroits g7 je
pense c'est inadmissible faute revient
au col avant beaucoup d'avant il devait
peut-être le roi g7
la différence on vous l'a montré que des
cinq ans on ne peut ne pas prendre ainsi
les blancs y prennent en fait on est
content ça fait gagner un thermos
exactement à d'ailleurs est en passe
contenant des patins et sideci sissy bar
même eu cinq d'ailleurs d'alors n'avait
diffusé si ce qui était logique mais au
5e ouais et on cherche le pion comment
ça marche donc 17 pouces et 6 il peut
faire d'un point je veux dire ça va ça
pour les classes annoncées soulager bon
ok donc on va voir si juste un petit
rené peau il a fait harper s'apprête
déjà tout analysé donc ouais mais on
n'est pas sûr du jugement en fait on a
analysé mme on n'est pas sûr on peut
encore boutiques et tu veux revoir le
tarif 5
daniel 5 pour contrôler des 5 prendra
les nature délicate
il y des comptes relève ses pieds pas de
menu déchets et la dame g4 houde a
réussi ce nomme g4 pour moi ces projets
d'amd 5 connect sur deux prend des 5 on
peut aussi jouer la même idée avec fois
ci ça marche aussi de ce côté là france
tombée quatre reprises et enfants de 6
et un même idée ça me prend à 2.837 sur
la même tu menaces en b1 qui menace en
d4
mais sitôt premiers signes d'un v6 à
zermatt et il peut pas te protéger l'un
d'eux me prends des quêtes
il revoit la tenir facile ouais mais tu
te trompes et de chance même les blancs
il faudrait faire dans le khat échanger
les dames au b2 ont permis d de justin
oui je voulais
facile donc du coup peut-être que ding
bien défendre on va voir parce que là il
faut quand même y trouve tout ça et 9
500 objets en fait on vous remontre
d'objets 4 qui paraissait plus logique
au début j'avais pas vu dans madame 8 h
salle et ont eu des fondus pour la tour
adam est tombée cet ici d'un mètre et
524 je pense d'un f4 sa force l'abandon
des cinq plages et occasion du ku'damm
f5 obligé alors pourquoi obliger parce
qu'on pense qu'après dame trombe et 5
toutes les finales bon pain oui sur
bensen donc l'enquêté quatre passes
prendre le match du couloir droit
je reprend 2,5 mais c'est pareil donc tu
en prends ton prend et en fait son
échange tout on avait l'impression que
ça a gagné assez facilement après non
mais ça l'a gagnée tranquille on a peur
de la chine qui est nouvelle
ouais alors attendez c'est de relancer
on va essayer de le relancer
donc
[Rires]
e